Good morning John.
This is a special bonus video not in response
to your last video but in response to my last
video, because I said something that didn't
make any sense.
I said that the majority of Muslims live in
Asia, not in the Middle East, and the reason
why this doesn't make any sense is because
the majority of the Middle East is in fact
in Asia.
Now my point plays out, if you subtract the
population of the Middle East from the population
of Asia, there're many more Muslims in Asia
than there are in the Middle East.
But the real problem with that statement is
that Asia is most people, like most of everyone
lives in Asia, more than half of the world's
people.
And as I was thinking about this, what happened
in my head is the entire concept of a continent
broke down and went away.
So we are taught, in America anyway, I don't
know what everybody else is taught, that there
are seven continents.
There's North America, South America, Europe,
Asia, Australia, Africa and Antarctica, the
one everybody forgets 'cause nobody lives
there.
To the people who are currently on Antarctica,
I apologize for saying no one lives there
but let's be honest.
What a continent is is supposed to be any,
like, large contiguous area of land that is
defined by ocean borders.
This works fairly well for North and South
America and Africa, it kind of breaks down
everywhere else, in fact it kind of breaks
down for North and South America which are
indeed connected to each other, and for Africa
which is connected to Asia.
And I guess it makes sense for Australia,
but is it just a really big island?
Or is it a really tiny continent?
I-unno.
And then Antarctica, don't get me started,
it's an archipelago under the ice and the
biggest island in the archipelago is smaller
than Australia.
And then you've got the elephant in the room:
Europe and Asia, which are clearly by any
geographical definition, the same continent.
The only reason Europe is a separate continent
is because I was taught by people who are
culturally European and they wanted it to
be.
But if there's any part of the definition
of a continent that is cultural, then there
is no excuse for one continent containing
Russia and Indonesia and Japan and China and
the Middle East and India and Pakistan...
What!?
Now this is exacerbated in my world by the
commonality of the Mercator Projection map
which makes lots of things that are very big
look tiny.
For example, last video, I was talking about
how the majority or Muslims lived in Indonesia
and that just seemed impossible to me because
Indonesia, in my head, is very small.
But then you drag it on up from the Mercator
projection and if it was in the same place
as Europe, it's... it's huge!
It stretches all the way from North Ireland
to fricking Kazakhstan!
Indonesia has the same land area as the UK,
Germany, France Spain, and Italy combined!
So what's my solution?
Do I think that Europe and Asia should be
one continent?
Or that Europe and Asia and Africa should
be one continent and North and South America
should be one continent, and then maybe Australia
and Anarcarpartita?
No, not really.
I think that continents are a useful idea
in grade school when you're introducing children
to the idea that the rest of the world exists,
but for adult humans, I think that it's time
that we move past this massive oversimplification
that leads to lifelong misunderstandings of
reality and discard the entire concept of
the continent.
John, you will see me tomorrow with my video
about the Global Goals which I am very excited
to share.
Everybody go to globalgoals.org if you haven't
done that already, so you can study up a little
bit before that video, 'cause you're gonna
want to know.
You're gonna want to know.
[Cereal TIme Intro]
Charlie: Ta-da!
Charlie: Would you like to see my collection
of pillows?
Chris: Give me the panini!
Jimmy: I am a long term friend and supporter
of the gnomes.
Jimmy: I've never played on one of these.
Can I have a play on this later?
Charlie: Yeah, sure thing.
Jimmy: What a fine looking horse she is.
Charlie: You know what, Jimmy?
I don't know if I agree.
Jimmy: How dare you!
Charlie: I heard us surius surm azur...
Jimmy: Charlie's broken.
Charlie: Jesus Christ!
That's science right there.
Jimmy: I think it's adorable in a way.
Charlie: Would you date it?
Jimmy: No.